>> Jill Garcia: Good morning.
Welcome to the National
Book Festival.
We are here to celebrate
reading books and authors.
You guys ready?
Yeah. All right.
The Library of Congress makes
this easy to do this every year.
But the truth is, the
National Book Festival is a
huge undertaking.
And I guess it is
free for everyone
because of the generous support
of our sponsors and supporters.
So a shout out to them.
Spread the joy of reading
with your gift online
at loc.gov backslash
donate from the festival app
or when you purchase
books today.
But let's get to what
you guys are here to see.
I am pleased to introduce
Minh Le and Dan Santat,
who collaborate together
to bring us a touching
and a delightful new picture
book, "Drawn Together,"
a story that explores
how a young boy
and his grandfather discover
the mutual love of art
and connect and bond over it.
But first, let me tell you a
little bit about the authors.
Writer Minh Le is a national
early childhood policy expert
and author of "Let Me Finish."
He has written for the New
York Times, the Horn Book,
the Huffington Post,
among others.
Le is a first-generation
Vietnamese-American
who loves spending
time with his family
in their home in Washington, DC.
Dan Santat is the
author and illustrator
of the Caldecott Medal-winning
"The Adventures of Beekle,
The Unimaginary Friend," as
well as "The Cookie Fiasco,"
"After the Fall,"
"Sidekicks" and others.
He is also the creator
of Disney's animated hit
show The Replacements.
He lives in Southern
California with his family
and a variety of pets.
Just so you know, they're
going to be signing
in line nine at 11:00.
Please welcome Minh
Le and Dan Santat.
[ Applause ]
>> Dan Santat: Woo, yeah.
>> Minh Le: Good morning.
How's everybody doing today?
>> Dan Santat: I don't
know about you guys,
but I was looking over at
the food show over there,
and I'm like I cannot
wait to get some nachos.
>> Minh Le: You want
me to go grab you some?
I'll be right back.
>> Dan Santat: You know
what I also want to do?
I kind of just want to barrel
into that tower of cardboard.
I don't know.
That's the kid in me.
Hey, listen, we have
a half hour,
so we got to get
cracking on this.
Let's hand it over to Minh,
who is the author of this book,
of this fabulous fine book that
I had the honor of illustrating.
So he'll read it to you.
He'll talk about his thoughts,
and then he'll hand it
over to me, and I'll just talk
about the goofy art process
that took place to
make the magic happen.
Just so you know, we're
actually not human beings.
We're actually animatronic
robots
that are powered by
your tax dollars.
I'm just animatronic Abe
Lincoln like at Disneyland, so.
Let's get this going.
>> Minh Le: I'll try not to
kick out your plugin then.
>> Dan Santat: I know.
I'm going to totally --
>> Minh Le: So as Dan
said, I am the author,
which means I wrote the
story and the words.
But as you'll see, most of the
story is actually wordless.
So it's a really amazing
treat to write a small text,
hand it off to Dan,
and see like the magic
that he was able
to pull together.
So as I said, we have
a little bit of time.
So we're going to get started.
>> Dan Santat: Going
to get cracking.
>> Minh Le: Right.
>> Dan Santat: Line nine.
>> Minh Le: So this
story is about family.
So it's inspired
by my grandfather,
all my grandparents,
particularly my grandfather.
I think Dan had a similar
experience with his grandmother.
>> Dan Santat: My grandmother,
the only grandparent I knew.
>> Minh Le: And we both
spoke different language
or primary language
than our grandparents.
Can I get people to raise their
hand if you have family members
who speak a different
language at home?
That's amazing.
Okay. So, yeah.
Do you also speak
that language at home?
If you do, please hold onto
it because I let it slip.
And it's something I
regret all the time.
>> Dan Santat: Terrible
grandson.
>> Minh Le: Yeah, I know.
But I wouldn't be able to
write the book if I kept --
>> Dan Santat: Right.
Because I was a terrible
grandson,
I got to illustrate this book.
So yay.
>> Minh Le: Terrible grandson
was the alternate title
for this book [inaudible].
Okay. So "Drawn Together" by us.
Let's see if I can
get this to work.
Okay. So the story begins.
Actually, that is a
picture of my grandfather.
Actually, I should
say our grandfather
because I'm pretty
sure about 30%
of the audience is
family members, so.
But my grandfather
and Dan's grandmother.
I wonder why I'm staying behind
here since we're mic'd up.
>> Dan Santat: Let's
just be sure
to make sure people can hear us.
>> Minh Le: So the story begins
with a boy being dropped
off by his mother.
And he goes up, and
he rings the doorbell.
And his grandfather answers.
And how does his grandfather
look when he opens the door?
He's like super happy, right.
>> Dan Santat: Oh my God!
>> Minh Le: And they
greet each other.
And the grandfather
waves goodbye to the mom
as she drives off and
invites the boy inside.
Now how does the boy look
when he goes inside the house?
He's a little bit unsure, right.
So they sit down to
this wonderful mean.
And the grandfather makes
himself this delicious bowl
of soup.
And because he's a very
considerate grandfather
and wants his grandson
to eat something,
he makes him a hotdog.
But also because he's a
responsible grandfather,
he adds a side salad
because, I mean,
you have to get the greens too.
Before we move on, quick,
I want to ask real quick.
If you were having this
dinner, raise your hand
if you would go for soup.
Okay. Me too.
Raise your hand if
you'd go for a hotdog.
Okay. Raise your hand
if you'd go for both.
Okay. Just the side salad.
Yes.
>> Dan Santat: I have some
summer weight to work off.
I'd just be the salad, just dry.
>> Minh Le: So they
sit down for dinner,
and they to have a conversation.
And the boy asks, so,
what's new, grandpa.
And the grandpa asks
a question in Tia.
But that's as far
as they can get.
They can't quite
understand each other,
so they continue
eating in silence.
So afterwards, they go
and sit and watch a movie.
and the grandfather looks
over to make sure
the grandson's okay.
It looks like a super
exciting movie to me.
But also, the movie is in Tia.
So the grandson asks, can
we watch something else.
And the grandfather
asks a question too.
But again, that's as
far as they can get.
They can't quite connect.
So they continue watching.
The boy's not too
psyched about that.
And the grandfather gives
a little bit of a side eye.
But the movie continued.
Then eventually, the boy
is like you know what.
I don't understand
what's going on.
He's done.
He walks off, and he
goes and grabs his bag.
And he pulls out some
paper and some markers.
Then the grandfather comes over
and peeks over his shoulder
and sees that the boy
is drawing a picture
of himself as a wizard.
How has that made
the grandfather feel?
He gets like super
excited, right.
So he runs off to his room
or goes as fast as he can.
I'm not sure if he's
actually running.
So he runs off and comes back
with his own sketchpad
and paint and brush.
So right when I gave
up on talking,
my grandfather surprised me by
revealing a world beyond words.
And in a flash, we see each
other for the first time.
And there, you see
the boy as a wizard
and the grandfather
paints a picture of himself
as a Tia warrior
from his childhood.
Now all the things we could
never say come pouring out.
And we build a new world that
even words can't describe.
I was going to let that
sit a second cause Dan's
art [inaudible].
>> Dan Santat: When he
gave me the manuscript
and it said build a world
that words can even describe,
I just thought, wow, this is
going to be quite the challenge.
[ Laughter ]
>> Minh Le: But just when
we're closer than ever,
[inaudible] right now, that old
distance comes roaring back.
So they were super close.
All of a sudden, they find
themselves on opposite sides.
And if you look closely, what
do you see on the boy's side?
The grandfather's staff, right.
And on the other side by the
grandfather is the boy's wand.
So the grandfather looks
over and his grabs the wand
and he points it
very dramatically.
And the boy looks down.
He grabs the grandfather's
staff.
Says but this time, I'm
not afraid because I know
that together, we can
make our way across.
And does anyone know what
happened to the dragon?
Does anyone see the
dragon anywhere?
Right, the bridge.
So he took them.
They faced that dragon, and
they turned it into a bridge,
and now they're running
across it.
And so, now, after years of
searching for the right words,
we find ourselves
happily speechless.
The grandfather and the grandson
come together and whereas
in the beginning, they didn't
know how to communicate,
they couldn't connect,
now, through their artwork,
they've found that common ground
and they finally feel one.
But then it's time to go home.
And the mother comes back,
and everyone's happy.
The grandfather and mother hug.
The boy looks very
content in the car.
And as they wave goodbye, what
do you see the boy holding?
The boy is holding one of
his grandfather's brushes,
and the grandfather is
holding one of the markers.
So they traded, and
then they wave goodbye.
So that is our story.
Thank you so much.
I hope you enjoyed.
[ Applause ]
But before I hand it off to Dan,
I did need one volunteer
from the group.
Let me see.
I'm going to have to choose.
Actually, is there someone
named Abby in this crowd?
Where's Abby?
Come, come up.
Abby and I go way back.
We've like been to
a whole bunch of --
>> Dan Santat: Nepotism.
>> Minh Le: So I'm
going to ask Abby.
Okay. There's a secret
about this book.
Who wants to know the secret
of this book, raise your hand?
Okay. If you don't want to know
the secret, then close your eyes
and cover your ears because
we're about to reveal.
>> Dan Santat: You can leave.
Good day.
>> Minh Le: Abby, can
you do me the favor
of taking off the cover
and showing people
what's underneath?
>> Dan Santat: Awe.
Thank you, Abby.
>> Minh Le: Thank you.
Thank you.
Can everyone give Abby --
>> Dan Santat: Big
hand for Abby.
Yay.
>> Minh Le: So as you can see,
underneath the book is the
sketchbook like the one
that the grandfather had,
which is a very nice detail
that Dan came up with I believe.
>> Dan Santat: Yeah.
So, you know, before
I do my little thing,
do you have like a cute,
little story that you can share
about your grandfather and you?
Like, do you have a story?
I have one about my grandmother.
>> Minh Le: Then you go first.
>> Dan Santat: Okay.
So my grandmother, you know,
and I, our thing was food.
She always wanted to
feed me like crazy.
And so, that was the thing
that we had in common.
But her English was
very limited.
But what she heard was like bits
and pieces that she would hear
that just actually kind
of carried to Thailand.
But then people in Thailand
would say these things,
and they didn't understand
what they were saying.
So I remember doing
yard work one day.
I was doing yard work.
And then when I was done
like putting all the leaves
in the trashcan, I hear
my grandmother saying,
okay, cigarette.
And I looked at her, I
was like what, like what.
And she just smiled
just really cute.
She's like, okay, cigarette.
And I said, what,
what does that mean.
And my mom was laughing.
And she said, so in Thailand,
when construction workers
are working and they're done
for the day, they take out
their cigarettes and they smoke,
and they say, okay, cigarette.
And then that's how they do it.
So my grandmother, my sweet,
sweet grandmother who wanted
to tell me that I was
done raking leaves.
She looked at me.
She said, okay, cigarette.
And that's my story
about my grandmother.
>> Minh Le: But just for the
record, cigarettes are not okay.
>> Dan Santat: Cigarettes
are the devil.
>> Minh Le: I don't have a funny
story off the top of my head.
But I will say that a lot
of people have asked me
what my grandfather thinks
about this book, if you
don't mind getting emotional
for a second.
So I actually never told my
grandfather what this book
was about.
And he ended up passing
away just
like the year before
the book came out.
But I never talked
to him about it
because like those earlier
scenes where the grandfather
and the grandson are sitting
there quietly next to each other
and not knowing how to talk,
that's straight out
of my childhood.
Like, I loved my grandfather.
Oh, man. I know that
he loved me.
But he was a man of very few
words, and I'm an introvert.
So we just kind of sit
there next to each other
on the couch, look
at each other.
>> Dan Santat: Like this is fun.
>> Minh Le: Yeah.
So while I was never able
to tell him about the book,
it means the world to me
that it is a book for him
and all my grandparents,
that they have a spot
on the shelf now, and that
my hope is that if even
like one person out there can
like read this book and want
to connect with someone
in their lives and do
so before it's too late,
then that would be great.
So please, go tell the people
that you love you love them,
and go give them a hug for me.
>> Dan Santat: Right, right.
Okay, so.
>> Minh Le: I mean, do
that without crying.
I think that was good --
>> Dan Santat: Really, have you?
I was going to unload,
just -- Fish sandwich.
Okay. Fantastic.
So I'm going to share a little
bit about the art process
because I'm an artiste and
that's what I do for a living.
So I actually taught
myself how to draw.
I went to the local library.
My library, they had all
these books and how to draw,
because my parents, they
didn't let me take art classes
because they wanted me to
grow up and be a doctor.
But I said I'll show you.
I'm going to go to the library.
I'm going to check
out this book.
This book is still
in publication,
"How to Draw Comics
the Marvel Way."
I read this thing
cover to cover.
You know, it was my bible.
It was my favorite thing.
For any of you out there who
are interested in drawing
and being artists, all
I have to tell you is
that it's not something
you're born with.
You're not just born with
the gifted talent of drawing.
It's like riding a bicycle.
And if you recall, when
you were a little baby,
you weren't a baby
riding a bicycle.
Like you had to get
on the bicycle
and like I practice pedaling
and learning how to balance.
And that's how you learned
how to ride a bicycle.
Same thing with drawing.
You just practice and
practice until you get better.
It's like pretending
you're Michael Jordan
on the basketball
court, shooting hoops
at three seconds
left on the clock.
You miss nine of them.
But eventually, that
tenth one goes in.
You go, I won the game.
So I would copy pictures
of Garfield.
I drew this.
If you're inquiring, the medium
is paper with Crayola crayon.
I drew this when I
was six years old.
And what you guys don't
see are the tons of ugly,
melted faced Garfields that I
was trying to draw before that.
Like it takes lots
and lots of practice.
And as I got older, I just
kept challenging myself more
and more.
And one of my favorite rituals
was to sit down in front
of the TV on Friday
nights at 8:00 PM in front
of the Dukes of Hazard.
And I would take -- Yeah.
Let's cheer for these guys with
a confederate flag on the roof.
And I would sit there with
a cover, and I would try
to copy it line for line.
I wouldn't trace over it.
I would try to look at it, and I
would try to draw it on a piece
of paper as best as I could.
Now this is an example of one
of the most challenging
things I ever did.
And I'm telling you this
story because I want you
to understand that, you know,
like with enough
practice, you can do it.
Now I remember this
took so long.
I was drawing, and then
the Dukes of Hazard ended.
And then 9:00 o'clock came
around, and my mom came
and sat down to watch Dallas.
And I was still drawing,
and Dallas was going
on in the background.
And then an hour
later, my mom gets up.
Dallas is done.
She leaves the room.
And I'm still working
on the Hulk.
And then Falcon crest came on.
And I'm still drawing the Hulk.
And then 11:00 o'clock
came around.
Falcon Crest was done.
And lo and behold, I was
finally done with this drawing.
And it was that day
I learned two things.
One, I can draw anything
if I put my mind to it.
And two, I love Falcon Crest.
Now to this day, I still sketch.
I still sketch pictures
of things that I like.
Now these are examples
of famous superheroes
that you might recognize
from all the movies.
Now I don't draw superheroes
the way they look on a screen.
I like to draw superheroes
my way.
So, you know, that group
may not look like the group
in the movie, but it's my group.
And I encourage all of you
guys to express yourself openly
and do things your way because
that's how we really diversify
things and mix things
up and have some fun.
Now, speaking of fun, I
do artwork traditionally.
I can use a pencil, a pen,
paintbrush, watercolors,
acrylic.
But I really work most
of my time on a computer.
I have an iMac at home.
So half the screen is
dedicated towards Netflix.
And the other half of the screen
is dedicated for Photoshop.
And I use this wonderful
device known as a Wacom tablet.
It's a digital pen and template.
And so, whatever I draw
on that surface shows
up on the computer screen.
It's a very, very powerful tool.
Now I'll give you an example
of how powerful Photoshop is.
Let's take the Crate
and Barrel catalog.
Oh, hoy. So you kids,
at your young age,
you're all about
reading Ranger Rick
and Highlights and
things like that.
But when you get to my age,
it's all about the Crate
and Barrel catalog.
The fall catalog's coming out.
Just pumpkin spice everything
is going to come out.
It's exciting.
Now let's take this wonderful,
new four in one Weber
Grill system.
now I'm a busy man.
I don't have time to get into a
car and drive down in my Prius
because that's all
we drive in LA.
I don't have time to get in my
Prius and drive down to a Crate
and Barrel and find this
barbecue grill and test it
out to see if I like it.
No. But with the power of a
computer, boop, there I am,
with the power of Photoshop
enjoying a quinoa burger
with that man because I
live in Southern California.
Now here's another one.
Here's a fine dining set.
Here's a fine hipsterish-looking
kitchen.
Again, I'm a busy man.
I can't get in my Prius and
drive down to a Crate and Barrel
and see if I can pretend eating
eggs here if like this set.
No. But with the
power of a computer,
there I am pointing at oranges.
I don't eat them because
they're high in sugar.
Now here we have a spread
from "Drawn Together."
Now a lot of the
influence in the work is
from the motherland
known as Thailand.
And I incorporated a lot of
traditional art that you find
in that country,
most of it coming
from the Buddhist
temples and so forth.
Like maybe up to the early 2000,
you didn't really
see a whole lot
of pop culture things
coming out of Thailand.
A lot of it was dedicated
to the temples and churches.
So here, we have a
picture of what would be
like a guardian at
a Buddhist temple.
And that's what inspired
the grandfather's outfit.
Although my culture loves
to be really ornate,
that's something
darling about them,
especially when you're sitting
there drawing every scale.
Speaking of scales,
here is a dragon.
This is a wonderful -- Like
that's real gold, folks.
Like they don't skimp
on the gold.
And for this project,
I took a brush pen,
and I actually drew all
these shapes and characters.
And then I would
put those elements
and I would put it
on a computer.
And I'm going to show you the
magic of how I made this spread
where the grandfather
and grandson face-off.
So here's an example of layers.
It's like drawing on
different layers of paper
that you can place
on top of each other.
And so, a piece like this will
take me about a day or two.
I've managed to work
fairly quickly.
But this book, the illustrations
varied from piece to piece.
Some pieces would take a day.
Other pieces would
take seven, eight days.
I really broke out of my
habit of how I usually work.
So honestly, a piece
wouldn't be finished
until I felt like it was right.
And it was really kind of
scary in experiencing it
because usually, I know
what the end product's going
to look like.
And in this case, it was
completely different.
It really broke me
out of my mold.
And honestly, this is the first
time I've ever gotten a book
manuscript that helped
me evolve as an artist.
And I thought it was fantastic.
So that's the final piece.
That took about two days.
I think we have like
five minutes left.
Would you --
>> Minh Le: Actually,
we've got two minutes.
>> Dan Santat: We
have two minutes left.
Do we want to do a quick
drawing demonstration,
or do you guys want to
answer some questions?
Okay. All right.
Well, good thing I
have a second mic.
I'm going to come over here,
and I'm going to ask you guys --
I'm going to show you,
you can draw anything
with three basic shapes.
The first shape is a circle.
I have just drawn you a ball.
Ooh. Now, if I draw another
circle on that, uh oh,
I have just made the death star.
Ooh. Now, if I draw
you a triangle,
I have just made
you a gnome hat.
Ooh. Now if I add
another line to that,
I've just made you a
slice of cheese pizza.
Now, if I add circles
to it, uh oh,
now I have just drawn you
a slice of pepperoni pizza.
Ooh. Now, the third and
final shape is the square.
Now, I have just
drawn you a box.
Yay. Or if you really
want to get imaginative.
I have just drawn you the
State of Colorado, ooh,
or you could look at this
and say it's a slice
of cheddar cheese.
But if I add circles to it, oh,
now we have made Swiss cheese.
That's my Swiss accent.
But if I take this Swiss
cheese and I add two eyes
and some eyelashes
and a nose and a mouth
and two square teeth, I just
made SpongeBob SquarePants.
Ooh. Now, I'm going
to do one last thing,
and then we're going
to go off and sign.
We're going to draw
an author, okay.
So I need your help.
What shape is an author's head?
circle. What shape
are an author's eyes?
Okay. What shape are
an author's pupils?
Circles. Drawing is
easy, Mr. Santat.
What shape are an author's ears?
Semicircles.
Two points to Gryffindor.
What shape is an author's nose?
Triangle.
>> Minh Le: Is this is triangle?
>> Dan Santat: What shape
are an author's eyebrows,
these big things?
I'm hearing a lot
of -- It's just --
No is the author happy to be
here, or is he sad to be here?
I'll be honest with you, folks.
I am completely indifferent.
I'm Dan Santat.
This is Minh Le, the cast
members of Crazy Rich Asians.
Thank you.
>> Minh Le: Thank you, all.
>> Dan Santat: Thank you.
Thank you.
Curtsey powered by your love.